I started out with this this amazing
quotation from William Osler the father
of modern medicine which is I think he
said this in the 1890s dysentery has
been more fatal to soldiers than powder
or shot powder shot being what they
killed people with in combat and the
statistics were amazing you look the
mexican-american war toys with diarrhea
and mexico seemed forever linked sadly
but the ratio of seven to one soldiers
killed from malaria from disease versus
combat wounds and a lot of it was
dysentery more than it was malaria was
dysentery and dysentery is an extreme
form of diarrhea where the pathogens are
invading the lining of the intestine to
the point where you have you have blood
and it's it's a serious situation you're
dehydrating and you're bleeding nowadays
you don't see soldiers dying of diarrhea
but what you do have is situations where
especially in Special Operations Special
Forces these folks who are operating say
out in Somalia Yemen in instantly
dealing with villages that are being you
know insurgents are coming in trying to
win people over there have they're
sitting down to meals with a lot of you
know like elders in the village eating
food that's not been refrigerated
necessarily water that's not filtered or
treated and they're getting sick at a
rate twice that of the average enlisted
service members so and and they are also
doing the really easy the high-risk
classified you know go in and take out
Osama bin Laden whatever they're doing
some of them are snipers there so it's a
situation then it may be a life-or-death
situation
to you know you can't sort of stop in
the middle of a mission and go excuse me
I'm dealing with some extreme urgency
I've got a duck behind a rock there
they're just in a situation where
they're gonna soil themselves and and
ice it was a interesting reporting
challenge I found myself in Camp lemon
yay in Djibouti where a lot of this
counterinsurgency work goes on the
Special Operations folks are off in
their own restricted zone but they come
in to the cafeteria with everyone else
so I had to approach strangers over
dinner
have conversations about diarrhea which
is an interesting reporting challenge
but they to them it wasn't a silly topic
you know it was it was serious and they
had a lot to say about it so that was
really interesting